In her interview, Tina mentioned the concept of homophily.
What is homophily?
Is it the observation that two words tend to be pronounced similarly
if they're in a social network?
Is it the fear that two people connected in a social network
might develop a blood disorder that interferes with clotting?
Is it the political movement that suggests that people should be allowed
to marry people of the same sex?
Is it the idea that nodes that are connected in a social network
are also more likely to share other characteristics?
Or is it the term used to refer to individuals who reside in the largest city in Pennsylvania?